Das Podcast du Faux, mit Jimmy, Jimbo, ey. Jim ist ja die Abkürzung von Jimbo, wahrscheinlich ist er Jimbo Meyer und Jimbo ist wiederum die Abkürzung von Jim Bartholomew. Jim Bartholomew. Und Jim Bartholomew wiederum, also es ist eine lange Dynastie. Eigentlich müssen Namen im Laufe der Zeit kürzer werden, oder? Also wenn man... Weiß ich gar nicht. Weiß ich auch gar nicht. Vor allem wo hat dann Jonathan angefangen oder Barbarara. Die war früher, früher, im 14. Jahrhundert war es noch Barbarara. Und dann hat sich das langsam so weggefeilt durch den Zahn der Zeit. Bis sie jetzt bei Barbar ist. Irgendwann ist Barbar. Barber. Und dann nur Barb. Ja, vielen Dank, Jim, für dieses fantastische Intro. Das ist die Kürze, die wir wollen. Das ist die Knackigkeit, die wir wollen. Und es hat für mich so eine alte Harald-Schmidt-Show-Assoziation geweckt durch das Französische. Aber gut, ich will es nicht zu sehr reininterpretieren. Das Kunstwerk steht für sich selbst. Vielleicht ist es auch ein französischer Jim. Jim? Ich weiß es auch nicht genau.
Jean. Da fällt mir gerade was ein, was ich eigentlich schon seit drei Wochen in der Podcast-Folge sagen wollte, und zwar Entschuldigung.
Und zwar, hallo, herzlich willkommen zum Volk-Grupp.
Mein Name ist Florian.
Sorry, wir können direkt mal reinsteigen.
Ja, ich muss auch ein bisschen.
Mit der grossen Das-Podcast-Ufo-Entschuldigung, Uldigung, Uldigung, Uldigung, Uldigung, Uldigung.
Und zwar, wahrscheinlich erinnerst du dich noch an unseren guten Humorkollegen Jasper den Witzigen. Jasper der Witzige ist in die Legendenkultur eingegangen, als der, der allen Widrigkeiten zum Trotz doch den Witz gezückt hat. Genau, weil wir haben mal wieder einen wagen Aufruf gestartet, das kurz da zum Catch-up. Die Idee war nämlich, macht in denkbar unlustigen Situationen einen Witz, denn da funktionieren sie am besten. Wir haben es gelernt, vor dem Hintergrund als Kontrastmittel der Ernsthaftigkeit wirkt eine kleine Banalität schon sehr lustig. In der Dunkelheit ist auch eine kleine Flamme hell. Genau. Im Wasser ist auch eine, ist Luft eine Blase. Im Ozean kann ein Streichholz nicht brennen.
Wenn man dieses Kontrastmittel schluckt beim Arzt, dann sieht man selbst den kleinsten Tumor wunderbar leuchten in der Dunkelheit. Völlig richtig. Und in dieser Tradition hat Jasper das Unmögliche gewagt, denn er hat versucht, eine Steuerprüferausbildung, sowas in der Richtung aufzulockern, was ja unmöglich ist. Daran sind die Besten gescheitert. Jim Carrey hat ja damals seine Ausbilder zum Buchhalter komplett humorlos durchlaufen, weil er nicht wusste, wo soll man jetzt hier immer so ein Hinn-Hinn-Hinn Hinn-Hinn einbauen. Generell bei so mathematischen Scheiss und so ist ja auch schwierig, dann Hinn-Hinn einzubauen. Robin Williams saß stockstumm, Mäuschen schüchtern in der letzten Reihe, hat nicht den Mund aufbekommen, hat keinen Gag rausgehauen.
Wobei just in diesem Moment fällt mir auf, dass die Frage, die der Dozent dann gestellt hatte, nämlich, was wollt ihr später mal machen, ja schon denkbar absurd ist. Korrekt. Ah, ich verstehe. Die Frage, wenn alle da zur Steuerausbilderprüfung da erscheinen oder zumindest beim ersten Seminar und der Dozent fragt, was wollt ihr später mal machen und alle sagen Steuerprüfer, ist das natürlich ein bisschen ein absurder Hintergrund schon, vor dem der Gag, ich will Feuerwehrmann werden oder Astronaut vielleicht nicht so zum Schallengelächter führt wie vielleicht. Das heißt, du sagst, jeder Doof braucht seinen Dick. Das heißt, man kann alleine nicht lustig sein, weil du brauchst eine Flanke.
Ich sage, selbst im Schnee erkennt man ja jeden kleinen Fuchs. Ja. Okay. Auf jeden Fall hat Jasper das Unfassbare getätigt, hat keine Lacher geerntet, aber er verzögert hat ihn bei uns bekommen. Stellt sich raus, der Gute heißt nicht Jasper. Ui, ui, ui, ui, ui. Das heisst, wir haben jetzt die Marmortafel in Auftrag gegeben, in das dicke Buch der Comedy haben wir das reingeschrieben mit so Zaubertinte irgendwie. Das dünne, machen wir uns sofort dünne Buch der deutschen Comedy. Ja genau, haben wir mit witzigen Rechtschreibfehlern irgendwie, haha, dann seinen Namen reingeschrieben, stellt sich raus, der heißt anders, ich habe aber vergessen wie. Okay, Jesus Christ, aber kannst du dich auf deine Entschuldungen besser vorbereiten? Wenn man sich auf eine Rubrik vorbereiten sollte, dann auf die Entschuldigungskategorie. Ich möchte mich entschuldigen für die heutige Entschuldigungsrubrik, die nicht so lief, wie ich wollte. Nein, meine Erinnerung schlägt mir ein Schnippchen, bietet mir aber was an. Nein, nein, nein, nein, pass auf, pass auf, pass auf. Also, das ist ja das Ding mit Gedächtnis, so, Gedächtnis ist ja auf meiner Seite. Gedächtnis sagt ja selten, du, wir haben nichts. Meins arbeitet gegen mich. Gib ihm mal irgendwas. Ja gut, aber in erster Instanz bietet es dir mal was an. Ja, ja, es füllt die Lücken. Es ist so ein Co-Moderator, der sagt, du, ich hab hier was, und erst am Ende merkt man, das war gar nichts. Nee, und zwar ist es wie, kennst du Wolfgang Beltracki, diesen Kölner Kunstfälscher, der immer in die Werkverzeichnisse reingemalt hat. Zum Beispiel, wenn irgendwie ein krasser Kampendonk hat zum Beispiel, dann gab es Aufzeichnungen, dass er angeblich dieses eine Werk hatte, zwischen dem einen und dem anderen, was verschollen galt. Und er hat dann quasi da reingemalt. Und so funktioniert, also hat er das interpretiert. Er hat nicht in das Verzeichnis reingeschmiert. Er war kein Schmierer. Nee, er hat dann quasi abstrakt ins Werkverzeichnis reingemalt, nämlich hat dann das Bild kreiert. Er hat nicht in das Verzeichnis reingeschmiert. Er war kein Schmierer. Er hat dann quasi abstrakt ins Werkverzeichnis reingemalt, nämlich hat dann das Bild kreiert. So, und jetzt... Du musst das auch ein bisschen für uns einfache Leute hier runterbrechen. Was ist das? Ja, okay. Und so funktioniert mein Gedächtnis. Da ist eine Lücke, wo mein Gedächtnis malt so kunstfälschermäßig in diese Lücke rein. Das stimmt. Und es ist immer, ist es schön, aber es ist meistens nicht das, was eigentlich da war. Ich hatte jetzt im Privaten gerade einen Gedächtnisfall, den wir vielleicht nochmal aufrollen können, aber es ist schwierig, gerade so Zeugenaussagen oder so sind vollkommen nutzlos, wenn jemand sagt, ja da, hast du da jemanden gesehen, da, keine Ahnung, bietet irgendwas an, ich kann jetzt nur mit dem gehen, was mein Gedächtnis mir anbietet. Es ist ein kleiner, schlichter Umschlag. Da ist ein Zettel drin, kein grosses Ding, hast dich hingeschmiert, noch mit Tinte verschmiert. Es ist aber alles, was ich habe gerade. Es ist die gesamte Bibliothek, auf die ich zurückgreifen kann. Und zwar hat nämlich eine besorgte Hörerin mich angeschrieben und hat gesagt, Achtung, Achtung, Achtung, hier muss repariert werden. Achtung, Achtung, Hörerinnen-Alarm! Und da hieß es nämlich, dass der Gute gar nicht Jasper Hörerinnen-Gewerkschafts- Achtungs-Alarm! Und sie scheint nämlich den guten Jasper zu kennen, der nicht Jasper heisst, sondern Jasper. Und damit beenden wir schlagartig und unbefriedigend die Rubrik die Entschuldigung der Woche. Stefan, was hast du noch vor, dieses Ne, genau, ne, ne, wir beenden die Rubrik natürlich nicht, weil auch ich habe groben Bockmist gebaut, groben Bockmist. Fagt man das so? Du hast dich richtig reingesetzt, kann man sagen, oder? Nee, aber ich erinnert euch vielleicht viele von euch an die Folge, ich glaube, vor zwei Wochen, vor zwei Folgen war es, als ich erzählt hatte, dass ich meine ... Nicht die Autoreifen, bitte! Nein, nein, nein. Das Auto ist mittlerweile so schrottgefahren. Nein, aber da funktioniert der erste Gang nicht mehr. Merkulis Problem. Ah, nein! Ich weiß nicht, was das Problem ist, vielleicht kann man damit. Nein, aber es geht um die VHS. Ich habe ja aus meinem Elternhaus 35 VHS weggebracht. Du hast das UFO-Clubgeld verprasst. So, und das wurde dann sehr teuer. Und ich möchte mich ein bisschen entschuldigen, weil wir haben nämlich dann die Firma des Scams bezichtigt. Die Firma war sehr nett. Ich war dann da, habe die Kassetten abgeholt. Genau, digitalisieren. Es wurde sehr teuer. Wegen Überlänge, weil du einfach den Hals nicht vollkriegst und irgendwie die halbe Staffel des Simpsons noch auf VHS haben wolltest. Naja, nochmal zu meiner Verlegung. Es wurde dann schon gesagt, dass die meisten haben keine Überlänge, die meisten sind gar nicht doll bespielt. Stellt sich raus, eigentlich ein bisschen eine Fehlinformation, weil die meisten sind bis randvoll bespielt, weil die einfach laufen. Ja, klar. Die werden einfach laufen gelassen. So, und dann habe ich, und die waren nicht beschriftet, deswegen musste ich die alle abgeben. Ich konnte nicht nur die Kinderaufnahmen und die Skiurlaube meiner Eltern retten, sondern ich musste auch dann einfach die Schatzinsel, der große Mehrteiler bei Sat.1, musste ich dann auch zu digitalisieren bringen mit den Tagesthemen hintendran und so ein Scheiß. Also das war auch alles.
War auch gar nicht schlecht, aber cool eigentlich, Zeitgeschichte. Ja. Das ging damals ab. So, und dann habe ich das alles, alle wegbringen müssen. Ich konnte jetzt nicht sagen, nee, es reichen nur diese drei, obwohl eigentlich waren nur drei Kassetten wirklich relevant. Musste alle abbringen und dann kam am Ende die Rechnung, es kostet sich immer noch 50 Euro und ich habe gesagt, oh mein Gott, dann machen wir nochmal ein paar mehr Werbungen. in der Folge. Aber genau, dass das passiert, dann war ich da und die waren wirklich sehr kulant, haben ja auch erklärt, warum sie nicht anrufen konnten vorher, denn sie merken auch erst, wie doll das bespielt ist beim Digitalisieren. Da haben die aber schon ihre großen Kohleschürfenden Dieselmaschinen angeworfen für. Ah, ich verstehe. Das heißt, die können sich nicht melden und am Ende, und sie haben mich ja auch unterrichtet, das stimmt auch, aber der Vertrag hat nicht unterschrieben, der hätte ich ein bisschen genauer lesen können.
Sie haben ja aber super nett sehr viel Geld erlassen, sie haben mir glaube ich 150 Euro oder so jetzt geschenkt, weil das einfach sehr viele Kassetten auch waren und es denen leid hat. Das möchte ich noch mal denen zugute halten, das heisst, ihr könnt alle, wir haben diese Firmen des Scams bezichtigt, ich möchte hiermit sagen, sind die nicht, die sind alle supercool, die sind nett. Bringt eure VHS dahin. Es ist teuer, natürlich, aber es ist auch aufwendig und die sind meistens kulant. Also meine Erfahrung, 100% der Firmen sind kulant. Die lagen jetzt eine Woche lang auf dem Trockenen, weil niemand mehr hingehen wollte wegen dir und deinen Verleumdungen, aber jetzt hebst du es wieder auf. Du hast laut Scam geschrien im Hintergrund die ganze Zeit. Scam, das glaubt du. Du hast eine Rolle, eine R betrug. Ich war letzte Woche ein bisschen überdramatisch. Das habe ich auch gemerkt, im Privaten auch. Da war ich ein bisschen drüber, da möchte ich mich auch für entschuldigen. Das tut mir leid, da sind einige Leute aus meinem Umfeld, haben da stark drunter gelitten. Jasper, Jasper, entschuldige. Jasper, genau. So, und jetzt habe ich die gesichtet. Ich hab sieichtet. Ich habe sie, die VHS-Kassetten, ich habe sie bekommen. Wieviel Stunden Material hast du jetzt? Es sind 35 mal 90 Minuten und von denen haben nochmal 18 Minuten für drei Stunden Laufzeit. Also wir reden hier wirklich von fast 70 bis 80 Stunden wahrscheinlich Material aus den frühen 90ern bis Ende der 90er im Free-TV. Also es fing stark an. Ich habe die gesichtet und habe jetzt mal aufgeschrieben, was alles so dabei ist. Und tatsächlich, nur drei Kassetten sind mit privaten Aufnahmen. Der Rest ist irgendquett. Okay, also es fing stark an. Kass der Eins, Star Wars 6. Wow, auf Deutsch?
Star Wars 6 von Polsieben aufgenommen, ich glaube, 96. Mich haben schon Leute angeschrieben, dass sie grosses Interesse hätten, weil irgendwie 92 oder sowas wurde dann, wurde Star Wars gezeigt zum ersten Mal im Free-TV, oder ich weiß nicht, zum ersten Mal, aber zumindest eine Version, wo dann in den Werbepausen auch noch so Interviews und Live-Show gemacht wurde, wo Leute darüber gesprochen haben. Also richtig so ein Fan-Event, wo glaube ich Fans auf der Suche sind danach und wirklich viel Geld bezahlen würden wohl. Also mir wurde schon Geld angeboten, ich glaube für meine Version aus 97 von ProSieben ist das jetzt nicht so spannend, aber ich muss noch mal genau checken, ob das nicht doch die, wie du vielleicht recht haben könntest, die Originalversion ist, weil die andere kam glaube ich später raus. Ja, die habe ich auch noch, die habe ich mir auch auf CD dann gebrannt, auch noch schön mit ProSieben-Logo, allerdings teilweise Bildtonschere, obwohl das gar nicht so wild ist, weil ja der erste Teil, ich glaube, bei Episode sechs beginnt ja der Film mit R2, D2 und C3, die keine Münder haben. Deswegen ist die Bildtonschere nicht so schlimm. Aber es fällt einem auch zu spät auf,
dass der Schere unguckbar ist.
Ja, und irgendwie ist es, im Laufe des Films fängt es sich dann so einigermaßen.
Nur der Anfang ist besonders schwer, da ist die Schere
besonders groß, aber idealerweise
sprechen Roboter, die keine Münder haben.
Also es ist perfekt gelöst.
Also man kann es richtig gut angucken.
Die Pieper haben jetzt nicht genau auf den Mund gepasst.
Also es fängt an mit Star Wars Rückkehr, derjenige finde ich super. Star Wars 5 war auf Platz zwei, auf Kassette zwei. Merkwürdige Reihenfolge, denn die Eltern waren damals schon wild unterwegs. Ja, oder sie haben einfach, die Reihenfolge von Star Wars hat sie irritiert. Dann Kassette drei, die Schatzinsel. Ah, jetzt fangen wir uns nochmal ein. Leg uns die Kürze nochmal aus, bitte. Was ist die Schatzinsel? Die Schatzinsel ist, glaub ich, ein deutscher Mehrteiler gewesen auf Sat.1. Ich weiß nicht, was er da verloren hat. Es sind, das zieht sich auch noch durch, sehr viele Sachen für mich so aufgenommen. Ich glaube, das war einfach ein Mehrteil. Du warst damals schon Piraten-Fan, das wussten deine Eltern und gesagt, die Schatzinsel, ich weiß es nicht, mir sagt das nichts, ich hab nur den Titel, sonst gar nichts.
Ähm, Kastette 3.2, TV-Total-Poker-Stars, die eh nacht.
Yes!
Und Random-Filme, also irgendwie, einmal draufgehalten.
Damals schon Pokerstars, Anfang der 90er?
Ich dachte, das wäre eher so ein ...
Das kann später gewesen sein.
Nuller-Jahre-Ding, dieser Poker-Hype.
Ich möchte sagen, dass der Rekorder war, glaube ich, länger im Betrieb
als nötig.
Vierte Kassette, Asterix und Obelix
und andere Random-Filme.
Fünfter Film, Christmas Vacation,
National Lampoon's Christmas Vacation.
Ein Film, den ich liebe, den ich
total gerne habe.
Auf Deutsch auch natürlich.
Dann Kassette 6, Super RTL,
Tierdokus auf Super RTL.
Da wurde einfach die ganze Zeit Super RTL angemacht.
Ich glaube, es war ein bisschen, um mich zu beschäftigen. Da wurde einfach so drei Stunden lang Super RTL aufgenommen. Ich glaube, um mich dann so vor den Fernseher zu verfrachten. Während deine Eltern die anderen VHS aufgenommen haben. Die VHS, die jetzt verschollen sind, aufgenommen haben. Aber ist die Qualität denn gut, oder hast du da dieses Flimmern und Zuckeln? Man hat genau das, was man will hat genau das, was man will. Also man hat Flimmern und Zucken, wie man das will, aber nicht zu einem Grad, dass es einen wahnsinnig nervt. Super. Ja, finde ich super. Dann, ah, die Kassel der Sieben ist dann fantastisch, ich und mein Kasselg Weihnachten, die große Weihnachtsdoku, die große Menschenstudie, ähm, mit dem Untertitel, warum man keine Einzelkinder auf die Welt setzen sollte, auch ein bisschen. Ja,schlochkinder bekriegen sich, aber es ist auch ein bisschen süss.
Dann gibt es, wie gesagt, acht Tier- und Dino-Dokus,
die sind fantastisch allerdings.
Die guten alten Dino-Dokus, wo der T-Rex noch ein Badass war.
Alle waren Badass, supergeile Dokus auch,
und die sahen auch richtig gut aus.
Ich habe sie auch fotorealistisch in Erinnerung,
waren sie nicht, stellt sich heraus. Also sind schon große CGI-Wesen, die durch die Wüste krabbeln, aber schon okay. Und die Tagesthemen vom 1.5.1997. Oh, was war los, 97? In vier Jahren 9-11, die müssen noch vier Jahre füllen, bis sie endlich was zu berichten haben. Was genau machen die da? Also, die war nicht so spannend, ehrlich gesagt. Es war der erste Fünfte, das war Tag der Arbeit, da wurde viel drüber gesprochen. Aber es gab schon die gleichen Probleme wie heute, also nicht lustigerweise, eher erschreckenderweise, aber viel Klima. Ja, 97? Ja, also erschreckenderweise sehr viel darüber erzählt, dass man sagt, okay, wir sind am gleichen Punkt wie 97. Dann auf Platz auf Kassette neun, Star Wars vier. Und ein bisschen von Independence Day. Aber wie gut, aber das ist echt wichtig, dass du alle hast, das ist schon gut. Das ist schon wertvoll. Zehn Ariel, ARD-Kram, elf ist dreieinhalb Stunden Super RTL, zwölf random ZDF-Film, da habe ich in Klammern schon die wütende Bemerkung, waren VHS-Kassetten nicht teuer, dass man einfach irgendwie angemangt, random ZDF-Film, der ja gar keine Rolle mehr spielt.
Naja, du wusstest ja damals auch nicht, ob er gut ist oder nicht, da gab es ja den RTL-Film der Woche und dann hast du gesagt, das ist ein Klassiker, du weißt ja nicht, ist es Titanic?
Wenn da einmal Titanic im Fernsehen lief und du hast gesehen, nein, okay, dann einfach für immer weg, das Schiff ist gesunken, es war's. Deswegen muss man natürlich auch ein bisschen im Voreinander aufnehmen. Dreizehn hat mich wieder total meine Kinder geholt, und zwar Dinotopia. Eine Serie, ein Mehrteiler, Dinotopia. Dinotopia? Ja, wo ich glaub so zwei Brüder, zwei Jungs, ist es Live-Action, ähm, Fiction-Reihe, wo die einfach in so eine Welt vorstoßen, wo die mit Dinosauriern koexistieren, die Menschen. Hatten die auch nur so Fetzen an, immer so braun? Ne, ich verwechsel es gerade mit dieser Meerjungfrau, die immer... Und das ist nie, glaube ich, also super trashig, aber super cool zu gucken. Weißt ihr noch, war ich damals ein Riesenfan von, wie sie so Flugtraining machen und dann auf diesen, ähm, Dingern, auf Flugsauriern durch die Welt fliegen. Hier habe ich ein Bild für dich. Googelt mal die Notopia. Spannend, also mit so einem Echsenbesen, was redet man. Also super trashy, aber auch ein bisschen zu campy. Also man guckt es dann auch wirklich gern. Und ich habe mich erinnert, dass ich es damals sehr mochte. Da hat Jurassic Park natürlich einiges ausgelöst, ne? Genau. Und Runaway Bride. Aber nein. Dann auf der Seite 14 The Next Uri Geller. Yes! Und das ist wirklich fantastisch, weil ich glaube nicht, dass man das ... Stop it! Stop it, Farid! Ah, stop it. Ich habe so reingescrollt und dann habe ich Vincent Raven gesehen. Und ich habe mich sehr gefreut, mehr als ich vielleicht sollte. Weil ich glaube nicht, dass man die noch irgendwo schauen kann, diese Folgen. Oh, das weiß ich gar nicht, ehrlich gesagt, ob die nicht von der Kirche irgendwann mal exkommuniziert wurden. Es nimmt dann ab Deutschland ein Sommermärchen, Ghostbusters wieder, ein bisschen Independence, erste Staffel DSDS, ich glaube das Finale, Evita, dann Peterchens Mondfahrt, Liebig, habe ich gestern auch mal geschaut, der alte Kinderfilm, nur zum Empfehlen, ganz toll. Erste Staffel DSD ist aber auch nicht schlecht. Finde ich auch nicht schlecht. Es ist heute Jesus, spielt heute Jesus in der Passion. Das ist auch eine steile Geschichte, von einem einfachen Menschen beim Casting zu Du bist jetzt Jesus. 21, Domino Day 97. Domino Day! Ah, yes. Das ist das Beste, glaube ich, was überhaupt jemals aufgenommen wurde. Freue ich mich jetzt schon drauf. Und den Werbeblogs. Pendel, ich liebe das Pendel. Ich liebe das Pendel und ich glaube, und vielleicht ist das nur in meiner Fantasie Gedächtnisschwierigkeiten zusammengebaut, aber ich meine mich daran zu erinnern, weil die hatten immer so Domino Day, Dominosteine fallen um und dann gab es so ein großes Pendel, das ist immer so ein Kreis pendelt und dann hatte man so Zeit für die Werbung. Und ich meine mich zu erinnern, dass irgendwann mal die aus der Werbung zurückkamen und meinten, oh, jetzt sind schon ein paar Steine umgefallen, weil das Pendel war nicht lang genug. Aber vielleicht habe ich das auch nur geträumt oder erfunden, weil ich es lustig finde, aber ich glaube mich zu erinnern, dass ich da dachte, nein, die müssen sich da super beeilen, wenn das Pendel nicht lang genug ist. Aber mega gut. Das finde ich richtig geil. Vor allem ist es ja doppelt lustig, weil VHS-Kassetten ja auch ein bisschen aussehen wie Dominosteine. Es ist so lustig. Es ist eigentlich zum Kaputtlachen. Es ist eigentlich wirklich zum Wegschmeißen. Und Video reint sich ein bisschen auf Domino. Also das ist wirklich zum Kaputtlachen. Da kommt wirklich alles zusammen.
Da kommt alles zusammen und Linda Demol ist auch noch dabei.
Ich kann mir richtig vorstellen, wie man diese
VHS-Kassetten nebeneinander aufstellt und dann
umwirft wie eine Domino-Reihe, wo überall
die verschiedene Domino 1, Domino Day 2,
Domino Day 3 und ich meine, das ist ja verrückt.
Also da wird es ja richtig wild.
Das ist absurd. Aber lasst die erst
digitalisieren, bevor sie umfallen.
Dann der Ski-Ulaub meiner Eltern, Independence Day wieder, also sehr häufig zieht sie durch. Wir lieben diesen Film. Jurassic Park und das Ende von Name der Rose. Nicht Spoiler! 25 ist meine Geburt. Oh Gott, wirklich? Also direkt danach. Okay, okay, sag das dazu. Ja, ja, ja, um meine Geburt herum. meine Taufe und wie ich zwei Jahre alt bin. Und da ist der tolle Moment erhalten worden, wie ich in die Mülltonne falle. Den kann ich vielleicht mal heraus ... Ja, das ist Patreon-Content. Das ist klassischer Ufo-Club-Content. Das ist, wir schlachten alles aus, was wir im Privaten irgendwie gefunden haben. Da falle ich in eine Mülltonne. Dann wieder Domino Day, dann dreieinhalb Stunden Super RTL, drei Stunden Kieker, Dino-Doku, Crappy Crab Schatzinsel Again, 101 Dalmatina, dann der Film Fire and Ice von Bogner, mega merkwürdiger Film, ein Film über Skifahrer. Und dann habe ich bei Wikipedia geguckt, was das für ein Film war. Ich wollte auch immer gucken, ich habe dann oft Schauspieler erkannt und habe die dann eingegeben, um herauszufinden, was das fürme sind, damit ich das mal gut archivieren kann. Und Fire and Ice steht drin, die Handlung des Films ist mehr oder weniger egal. Dem Regisseur ging es einfach nur darum, coole Aufnahmen von Skifahrern zu machen. Aber jetzt bin ich aber sehr gespannt, in einem Film über Skifahrer, der Fire and Ice heißt, also Ice, klar, kann ich nachvollziehen, aber wo genau kommt Feuer hier ins Spiel? Zwischen den Charakteren ist, glaube ich, ein bisschen Fire. Ach so, okay, da bin ich gespannt. Ich wäre immer nur auf der Suche nach dem Feuer. Fantastisch. Wenn ich diesen Film anschaue. Ja, ja, ich auch. Dann Das Boot, dann dreieinhalb Stunden Super RTL und Kika wieder, also für mich, um mich vom Fernseher zu setzen, und 35 in einem Land vor unserer Zeit. Ich bin zufrieden. Das ist eine Top-Auswahl. Und ehrlich gesagt, wenn ich das vorher gewusst hätte,
hätte ich das wahrscheinlich doch hingebracht,
weil Domino Day,
The Next Uri Geller, die Pokersassdee-Nacht
und die ganzen 90er-Werbeblöcke, glaube ich,
machen sehr viel Spaß.
Geil.
Da macht er mal so einen schönen Abend,
dann kommen wir alle vorbei,
alle Hörer und ich kommen bei dir vorbei
und dann schmeißt man den Fernseher an
und dann machen wir wirklich mal so vier Stunden 90er-Jahre-Fern richtig wegkulten. Man müsste eine 90er Jahre Party machen. Sich mal so richtig wegkulten, da kann das ja in Endlosschleife laufen. Das finde ich super. Es ist eine 90er Jahre Party, alle kommen so 90er Outfits, aber nicht so trashy, sondern wie es wirklich war, so sehr realistisch. Und im Fernsehen läuft die ganze Zeit... Uri Geller. Uri Geller. Ne, das war ja nicht 90er, aber sowas wie Domino Day aus den 90er. Ja, inino Day aus den 90, in die viermal hintereinander. Finde ich richtig gut. Also ich habe leider keine Zeit an dem Abend, aber... Nee, nee, du hast keine Zeit. Leider bin ich immer verhindert, leider. Du bist auch verhindert. Da ist leider jetzt wieder Heizungsablesen und ganz schlimm, kommt jetzt alles zusammen, alles am gleichen Abend. Heizungsablesen diesen Abend. Ja, ja, ja, ist ja ein hoher, ich wohne ja in so einem hohen Haus, da muss der ganz von unten nach oben, muss alle abklappern nach oben und es dauert teilweise Stunden. Du wohnst ja schon im 28. Stock. Ja, 98. Stock. Und das ist natürlich. Hoch, das ist der höchste Stock Kölns. Richtig hoch, ja, ja, ja, ja. Weiss auch nicht, was ich mir dabei gedacht habe. Was hast du dabei gedacht? Alles im Aufzug musst du ja immer immer alles hoch mitnehmen, ne, aber wenn ich mal was habe. Aber hast ja nicht so viel. Ich habe kaum was, habe kaum was, aber Heizung, wenn der kommt, muss ich wieder aufräumen. Okay, ne, dann muss er nicht kommen. Ne, aber wirklich, ich wünsche euch viel Spaß. Ich finde es ja auch verlegen, weil die Party, du hast zu früh abgesagt gewissermaßen, weil das Dachum steht. Bei mir ist echt randvoll, leider, der ganze Monat. Ne, ich kann immer, ich kann immer, kann immer. Nee, leider bei mir ist alles, ich habe ja die nächsten viereinhalb Jahre keine zwanzig Minuten Zeit, da ist alles, da jagt der eine Termin den nächsten. Aber ganz ehrlich, es gibt doch Leute, die nicht zwischen den Zeilen lesen können, oder? Oder hören können, wenn man im Gespräch Menschen, die, obwohl man absagt oder nicht antwortet, dann trotzdem so eine Penetranz an den Tag legen und sagen, nee, kein Problem, ich kann immer, sag du doch mal einen Termin oder sowas. Also wo man wirklich dann einfach komplett brach ist, weil ich meine, du sagst häufig ab und es ist auch fein und da reicht manchmal ja einfach so ein Wink, man checkt das ja, wenn derjenige keinen Bock drauf hat oder nicht der Typ dafür ist oder sowas. Aber man versteht das bei manchen Leuten einfach nicht. Die kriegen dann diese Zeichen nicht mit und dann kommt sowas wie, nee, aber ich kann immer nächsten Monat, da bin ich doch sehr flexibel, sehr flexibel und dann sag mal für einen Monat ab. Sag das mal. Ja, ist schon schwierig, ja. Oder das Schlimmste ist, und da bin ich auch da mittlerweile dabei, meinen Menschenfilter anzuschmeissen, um mit den Leuten nichts mehr zu tun zu haben, dass man sagt, ah nee, an dem Abend kann ich leider nicht, und die dann sagen, warum nicht? Ich denke so, okay, pass auf, es ändert nichts an den Fakten, warum musst du wissen, warum nicht? So, das muss reichen, dass jemand sagt, nee, sorry, der Abend passt bei mir da gar nicht rein. Warum denn nicht?
Ja.
Und dann so, ja, weil ich da Skispringen schaue oder was willst du jetzt hören? Was willst du jetzt für mich hören? Das ist, glaube ich, unhöflich, dass du jemanden in die prekäre Lage bringst, jetzt sich irgendwas aus der Nase zu ziehen, zu sagen, da hat mein Neffe Geburtstag und ich habe ihm versprochen, dass ich im Dino-Kostüm auftauche. Ja, aber das ist doch nur nachmittags. Ja, dann komme ich eben! Ich meine, wohin soll das führen? Vielleicht musst du doch so einen Salat mitbringen oder so. So dieses Leute überreden, gegen ihren Willen. Du willst doch nicht, dass Leute gegen ihren Willen bei dir auftauchen. Aber das hatte ich sehr häufig, dass ich mich irgendwann in so Rechtfertigungsgesprächen wiedergefunden habe, wo ich dazu überredet wurde, mit Leuten Zeit zu verbringen. Und ich denke mir so, haben diese Menschen keinen Stolz, gemein formuliert, oder merken sie es nicht. Aber so jemand, ich würde mir doch nicht die Blöße geben, jemanden zu überreden, mit mir Zeit zu verbringen. Das stimmt. Aber ich denke, wenn er das nicht will ... Nee, ich bin so narzisstisch, ich versuche die Leute sogar davon abzubringen, mit mir Zeit verbringen zu wollen. Nee, bei mir ist meine Wohnung superkalt, der Abfluss ist raus. Ich bin ein Riesenarschloch. Und die Leute so, nein, ich will unbedingt mit dir Zeit verbringen. Du so, nee, das ist wirklich, ich bin privat auch ein ganz anderer Mensch und so. Und nur wenn die wirklich alles geben, dann sage ich, ja, okay, dann schon. Also bei mir muss man sich andersrum erarbeiten. Okay, ja, also ich find's wirklich spannend, weil manche Menschen, ist es fehlende Empathie oder ist es so einfach eine gewisse soziale Recklessness? Kann auch sein, dass man's einfach durchdrückt. Ja, weil so, was soll denn schiefgehen mässig, einfach so, man muss nicht manchmal, vielleicht denken sie, dass man uns zu unserem Glück zwingen muss. Ich glaube, es sind nicht alle so verlogen und hinterhältig wie wir, die versuchen so hin. Aber es ist doch nicht verlogen, wenn man keine, es ist nicht verlogen, keine Lust zu haben, das aber nicht zu sagen. Ja, aber man sagt ja, ja, das ist ja das Ding. Aber das ist doch nicht verlogen, das wäre auch verletzend zu sagen, nee, pass auf, ich habe gar keine Lust, an dem Abend zu dir zu kommen, zu der 90er-Scheiß-Party. Also ich hab nichts gegen deine Wohnung, aber was gegen dich konkret.
Also ich mag dich nicht.
Das ist mein Problem.
Wenn du nicht da wärst, gerne.
Also die Vorstellung, an dem Abend bei dir zu sein,
würde jetzt schon Bauchschmerzen in mir auslösen.
Und ich würde die ganze Zeit nach möglichen Ausreden suchen.
Ich weiß nicht, ob das gut ist, das zu sagen.
Das wird leider, glaube ich, nicht verlogen zu sagen,
nee, an dem Abend hat meine Tante Notdienst. Not. Und ich muss währenddessen auf ihren Rottweiler aufpassen, der leider aktuell …
Im Krankenhaus.
Der ist leider gerade im Krankenhaus. Der ist an Silvester ganz dumm in so eine Fontäne reingelaufen.
So, ich dachte, was ganz anderes an Silvester ganz dumm in so eine Fontäne
reingelaufen.
Ich dachte, das ist ganz anders, Silvester Unrelate.
Der ist an Silvester ganz blöd
hingefallen.
Blöd so eine Brücke runtergefallen
und dann
jetzt seitdem hat der wirklich, also vor allem
alle vier Beine gebrochen.
Das heißt, der läuft jetzt wie auf so Stelzen, viermal Gips mit Rädern unten drunter. Das heißt, du musst den halt schieben, wie so eine Holzente hinter dir herziehen. Wie eine Tigerente. Wie eine Tigerente. Der kann nichts mehr alleine machen, der kann das auch nicht bewegen. Und da muss ich mich jetzt halt um ihn kümmern. Warum? Ja, gute Frage. Ja, ich komme. Okay, dann bin ich dann doch dabei. Und ich bringe meinen Nacho-Schichtsalat mit. Oh, lecker. Deswegen der Aufruf, wenn Leute euch sagen, da kann ich nicht oder so, vielleicht nicht auf dem Zahlen. Schneller aufgeben, sofort aufgeben. Wollen wir uns nicht mal treffen? Ja, da kann ich nicht. Nö, dann nicht. Dann machen wir an dem Tag lieber gar nichts. Dieser Podcast ist wirklich ... Hat so vieles Privatleben beendet, einfach auch. Aber ich glaube, ich würde sogar Partys veranstalten, nur um sie abzusagen. Weil ich kenne viele Leute, die mögen nichts mehr, als das abgesagt wird. Und da musst du auch proaktiv reingehen, so eine Party veranstalten, so richtig drei Tage lang irgendwie auf einer Insel, einer Schatzinsel. Komm, ich lade euch ein, große Schatzsuche. Dann gehe ich hier in den Schatzsuche. So am Independence Day. Könnten wir auf einer Schatzinsel Ski fahren oder so? Das wäre doch mal eine interessante Idee. Und dann haben alle ihre Ski und müssen aber im Schnee einen Schatz finden und so. Und das ist drei Tage. Und dann am Tag sage ich, ah Leute, jetzt ist die Maschine abgestürzt. Jetzt können wir doch nicht. Jetzt habt ihr das Wochenende frei. Ja, Independence, aber guter Film. Richtig guter Film. Ich mag den sehr gerne, ich finde den fantastisch, ich finde den super. Also der Anfang ist auch so schnell und toll erzählt und richtig. Oder ist es die VHS, die vielleicht so ein bisschen zu schnell ist. Doppel der Geschwindigkeit. Das ist wie schnell die laufen und so, man hat so richtig das Gefühl von Aliens und sowas, richtig gut. Ach Gott, also ja, also von mir eine Entschuldigung, um jetzt diese Rubrik auch mal endlich zu beenden. Ja, also es ist kein Betrug, VHS-Digitalisierung ist kein Betrug, soweit wir wissen. Soweit wir wissen, wir haben ja auch nicht alle Informationen. Wir haben jetzt keinen Zugriff in die Buchhaltung bekommen. Das stimmt, also da müssen wir noch mal in die Zahlen gucken, klar, das machen wir natürlich auch gewissenhaft, aber sowas von dem, was wir sagen können, nicht. Aber wo wir gerade bei technischen Schwierigkeiten für Entertainment-Genuss sind, ich krieg's nicht hin, White Lotus Staffel zwei zu schauen. Sky is the Limit, Sky stellt mir ein Bein, weil Sky ist ja der einzige Streaming-Dienst, der diesen fantastischen Player noch mal extra hat und nicht im Browser abgespielt wird. Und da ist es anscheinend so, dass ... So ein exzentrische Player. Sky ist so, ha, benutzt meinen Player. Ja, es ist auf so vielenen frech einfach so. Das ist wie wenn du eine Wohnung hast. Ich bin Sky. Ich habe den Kopf in den Wolken. Mein Name ist Sky. Und nicht nur das, mein Streamingprogramm heisst Wow. Weil wenn ihr es seht, dann sagt ihr Wow, hier ist mein Player. Mein anderer Player eröffnet sich, ihr müsst ihn runterladen.
Und dann müsst ihr jedes Mal die Sprache wieder neu einstellen.
Und wenn ihr die Sprache ändert, dann bricht alles zusammen.
Ich soll mir merken, auf welcher Sprache ihr das schaut.
Ich bin schade, mir ist alles egal, ich schau es an oder nicht. Das ist so, wie wenn du jemanden besuchen würdest zu Hause und der sagt, schön, dass du da bist, lass uns kurz in eine andere Wohnung gehen. Und du sagst, warum sind wir nicht in einer Wohnung? Nee, nee, ich habe extra eine Wohnung, wo ich hingehe, wenn Leute kommen. Du gehst auf die Browserseite und ich sage, jetzt würde ich gerne anschauen, er sagt, ah wunderbar, dann gehen wir doch jetzt mal kurz
zwei Strassen weiter, die nehmen dann so einen Schlüssel vom Haken,
stecken sich in die Tasche und sagen,
ah wunderbar, dann gehen wir jetzt zwei Strassen weiter und dann denkst du,
warum, wir stehen, wir sind schon da.
Und dann fragt er dich, hast du
einen Schlüssel und du sagst, ah ich glaube schon,
aber du hast nicht den richtigen Schlüssel,
aber du hast nur drei Versuche, den richtigen
Schlüssel reinzustecken, weil dann
musst du an deine Postadresse, versteht die Metapher, dann musst du an deine Postadresse deinen Schlüssel schicken lassen.
Wenn du da bist und es schaut jemand zu, dann wird es nicht abgespielt. Also der muss weg. Und dann sagst du, der gehört gar nicht zu mir, ich kenne den gar nicht. Ja, aber der schaut zu, das darf nicht starten. Und dann war es dann doch der zweite Schlüssel, den du für alles benutzt und dann gehst du rein und sprechen alle Französisch.
Und dann denkst du dir, nee, aber dann drüben das Haus, wo HBO draufsteht, da bin ich eigentlich lieber. Und das wäre mein Tipp. Ich glaube, es ist besonders frech. Die Serie The White Lotus spielt in Italien und es gibt Figuren, die nur Italienisch reden. Und es ist also Englisch, Italienisch. Mein Lifehack, seitdem lerne ich du auf die Moringo Italienisch.
Ja, glaube ich, muss ich jetzt nämlich auch.
Denn das Problem ist nämlich das, wenn du es im Original anschaust, so wie ich es verstehe, sind die italienischen Teile untertitelt. Jetzt ist es aber so, dass ich gehe davon aus, dass für die deutsche Fassung alles eingedeutscht wurde, so dass wenn du jetzt die Untertitel anmachst, Sky nur die deutschen Untertitel zur Verfügung hat, wo natürlich die italienischen Sachen nicht untertitelt sind. Wenn du keine Untertitel anmachst, sind die italienischen Sachen nicht untertitelt, weil der davon ausgeht, dass wenn man die deutsche Version schaut, ja keine Untertitel für die italienischen Segmente braucht, weil es auch deutsch ist, aber davon gehe ich aus. Aber das ist so bescheuert. Das heißt, du schaust jetzt diese Serie, du hast die englischen Teile auf englisch, die italienischen Teile auf italienisch, ohne Untertitel, weil es in der deutschen Fassung nicht vorgesehen ist, dass nur die untertitelt werden. Das heißt, ich schaue diese Serie an und verstehe kein fucking Wort! Ja, ja. Ausser Allora und Si.
Und Andiamo.
Und Andiamo, und da komm ich nicht weiter und ich denk mir,
habt ihr eigentlich einen kompletten Schaden?
Ich würd diese Serie gerne sehen, und ich zahle Geld,
und ich sitze da, und ich hab mir schön meinen Grappa eingeschenkt,
und einen schönen Becher Gelato,
und ich hab richtig Lust auf dieses Italieno-Feeling.
Äh, Azzurro, da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da Becher Gelato und ich habe richtig Lust auf dieses Italieno-Feeling. So sitze ich da und sage ... Du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du so schlecht. Und das heißt, ich kann die Serie nicht anschauen, weil ich sonst immer Untertitel für alles anmachen muss. Und dann muss ich mir den Untertitel lesen. Und es ist so fucking nervig, weil es ist eine gute Serie, die Leute haben sich so viel Mühe gegeben. Die stehen da in Italien rum und sagen ihren Text und die mussten jedes Wort auswendig lernen. Da steht nicht jemand hinter der Kamera mit einer großen Karte. Das ist immer so eine Schauspielersicht auf die Dinge. Dann haben die da ihre Sachen auswendig, weil das ist das einzige, was die Geschäfte haben. Die mussten das auswendig lernen. Die haben nachts da gesessen noch mit einer Lampe in ihrem Trailerchen und haben das noch auswendig gelernt, sind morgens pünktlich erschienen, wurden fertig gemacht. Mussten davor vielleicht noch warten, waren erst im Make-up, mussten dann noch fünf Stunden warten, konnten da nicht viel machen, weil sie schon Make-up hatten und Kostüm und so und dann tauchen sie auf und konnten den Text und ich denke mir, das muss man respektieren. Und ich sitze aber da und kann es nicht anschauen, weil einfach die technischen Möglichkeiten mir im Weg stehen. Ich prangere das mittlerweile wirklich hart und unbarmherzig an. Es tut mir leid, aber ich bin wirklich an einem Frustrationslevel, wo es auch in eine gewisse Militanz umschwingt. Und ich bereit bin, Mittel zu ergreifen. Im Ruheabteil hatten wir das zuletzt. Ja, allerdings, und auch da wurden die grossen Geschützer aufgefahren. Eine Petition. Nein, ich bin bereit, jetzt den nächsten Schritt zu gehen. Change.org? Ja. Meine Armee heißt Change.org. Meiner Erfahrung nach gibt es ja zwei oder mehr ... Wir hatten sogar bei How to Sell richtig viele Bildversionen, weil ja auch teilweise, wenn man das mit Untertiteln gucken müsste, in einer Sprache, ja irgendwie so drei Zeilen Untertitel passieren könnten, weil ja auch viele Handyscreens zu sehen sind, wo man Nachrichten lesen muss. Die wurden in die grossen, glaube ich, sechs Sprachen auch noch übersetzt und dann draufgepielt. Also da wurde dann noch mit computergenerierten Images das draufgespielt. Und deswegen, es gibt verschiedene, ich glaube, das nennt man Localizations, also verschiedene Bild, also wie Untertitel, die du ausstellen kannst, kannst du auch das Bild ändern in verschiedene Sprachen. Ich verstehe, ja, so bei Pixar-Filmen ist dann auch manchmal der Ladenname dann in Deutsch. Richtig, genau. Aber trotzdem wird es immer noch vorgelesen, das ist nämlich die Idee der Macher ja eigentlich, immer Macherinnen, dass sie das doch vorlesen lassen. Deswegen wird immer, wenn man das liest, bei den Simpsons zum Beispiel, wenn man was gelesen wird, ist eigentlich auch folgend. Jedenfalls verstehe ich das nicht, weil das müsste, eigentlich ist die Erklärung doch ganz, ganz einfach. Und es ist ja auch nie so, das soll man mir mal zeigen, in welchen Fällen viel gesprochen wird in einer Sprache, die nie übersetzt, die man dann übersetzen sollte auf Deutsch. Also, das macht gar keinen Sinn. Die Intention von Mike White war ja, die reden Italienisch und die Untertitel sind da wichtig. Dann sollte man das auch auf Deutsch, auch auf Italienisch lassen. Da möchte ich jetzt auch niemandem was vorwerfen, was nicht passiert ist. Das ist nur meine Interpretation, warum die nicht untertitelt werden. Es gibt keinen anderen Grund dafür. Fremdsprachen müssen untertitelt werden, und ich finde es merkwürdig. Wie frech wäre das denn, wenn die sagen, wir übersetzen den italienischen Teil ins Deutsche? Wie frech das wäre? Das wurde doch bei Inglorious Bars auch nicht gemacht, oder? Da wurde der englische Teil ins Deutsche übersetzt, Deutsche ins Englische übersetzt, und der der Französische wurde französisch gelassen.
Es macht aber keinen Sinn mehr, es macht gar nichts mehr. Auch bei Django Unchained macht's auch alles keinen Sinn.
Es ist alles so, lass doch einfach uns auf Originaltöne einigen und so, da ist eh mehr Arbeit reingeflossen.
Aber, ja, ich weiß es nicht, also ich find's merkwürdig, ist es sehr einfach zu beheben, das Problem eigentlich,
und deswegen wäre mein Tipp, besorgt euch Freunde, Freundinnen in den USA oder sucht im Internet danach oder keine Ahnung, fragt irgendwen, der mal da ist. Das hat aber gar nichts mit Streaming zu tun, sondern ich soll einfach mehr Freunde haben oder wie. Warum soll ich, rufe ich dich zu oft an oder? Jetzt kommt es und jetzt, ja ja, also deswegen wäre cool, wenn du mir einfach mehr Freunde besorgen könntest dir. Aber ich habe doch schon Freund Freund dich. Ja, aber weil es sehr viel Aufmerksamkeit auf mir und sehr viel Druck auf mir. Und ich denke so, ich kann das nicht mehr alleine auf meinen Schultern verspüren. Deswegen brauchst du mehr Freunde in den USA, also möglichst weit weg. Oder Australien. Hat Jim Zeit? Jim? Ey Jim, du, der das Intro gemacht hat, falls du Bock hast, ruf mich an. Ich weiß nicht, ruf mich an. Du kannst dann HBO, nämlich einen Account machen, dann besagt euch ein VPN und guckt auf HBO. Das geht ganz, ganz einfach. Ich schau White Autos auf HBO. Ich geb jetzt noch eine Chance mit The Last of Us, und dann schauen wir, ob das klappt auf Sky, und wenn nicht, dann bin ich raus. Das ist jetzt mein letzter Ultimatum. Das sage ich jetzt hier in diesem Raum, das erreicht niemanden, niemand kriegt das mit, aber das ist jetzt einfach mal was. Du hast deine Pistole auf die Brust gesetzt von Herrn Sky. Sky Dumont hat jetzt ein Problem. Hey, nehmen Sie die Pistole von der Brust. Hey, pass auf. Mein Name ist Doktor Sky. Ich gebe dir noch eine Chance. Okay. Last of Us, wenn das nicht klappt, wenn da wieder irgendwelche Sperenzchen sind, ja, wenn sie da wieder ankommen mit irgendwelchen Nicht-Synchron-Fassungen oder ich ständig umschalten muss oder irgendwas übersetzt wird. Hören Sie, es gibt Lizenzprobleme. Es gibt teilweise Lizenzprobleme. Ich hätte nicht immer die gemacht, okay? Du, pass auf, es ist dein Job, dass diese Lizenzprobleme gelöst werden, ja? Ich kann auch sagen, es gibt Probleme, es gibt Probleme.
Wie sind Sie ins Haus gekommen, wie sind Sie in meine Villa gekommen?
Nun, ich habe mir zwei Schlüssel vom Portier geholt, bin dann extra hier nochmal reingelaufen und habe gesagt, ich wäre Italiener und dann hat niemand mehr nachgefragt, weil kein Mensch in diesem Haus spricht Italienisch. Verdammt.
Also das ist jetzt die letzte Chance und ansonsten haben wir ja drüber gesprochen, wir waren ja beide große Fans von, wie hieß es nochmal, Fast, Fast, Fast.
No Fucks Given, der Podcast.
Also unsere Empfehlung für heute ist, wie heißt der hier, die Schlangen, ach irgendwas mit, ich weiß nicht genau, aber der war echt gut und ein Album ist mit diesem, das war echt geil. Aber nee, wir haben es doch gesehen, so dieses, sei so schnell, du kannst mein Freund, fahr so, fahr schneller, Windschatten ist für dich nichts, driving, strive to drive oder irgendwie so was. Baby Driver. Nein. Was meinst du? Das ist Crazy, Drive Me Crazy. Drive to Survive? Drive to Survive! Ja. So, und damals haben wir gesagt, wie geil wäre denn so eine Art von Doku über jede andere Sportart, die es gibt. Der Welt, ja. Jetzt kommt die nächste. Für? Von den Machern von Drive to Survive. Kommt. Jetzt sag mir mal deine Top-3-Sportarten, auf die du Bock hättest, so eine Art von Serie, die wirklich mal reingeht mit den Leuten, sprich Talking Heads, wirklich Aussenseitern auch wirklich diese Sportart genüsslich macht, wo man sagt, oh geil, da habe ich Bock, jetzt verstehe ich überhaupt jetzt, was überhaupt Formel 1, was das bedeutet, was die Leute überhaupt machen den ganzen Tag, jetzt verstehe ich das mal, in welche Welt würdest du gerne eintauchen, von welcher Sportart? Platz eins, Ice-Forky. Okay. Aus aktuellen Gründen, aus aktuellem Anlass. Platz zwei, E-Sports. Okay. Das ist ja eine Sportart, da kann man ja allgemein mal reingucken, E-Sports. Für mich ist das ein Brei, also die grosse E-Sports, Weltmeisterschaft zum Beispiel oder so. Auf Platz drei wäre ... Es muss ja ein Nischensportler sein, dass man sie ein bisschen anderen Leuten beibringt. Und da denke ich konkret an Schach. Es ist Golf. Oh. Ja. Aber ich hab ein bisschen Bock drauf. Weil genau wie Formel 1 ist es so ein Sport, wo ich dachte, eigentlich langweilig, aber ich glaube, wenn man da mal so richtig hinter den Schläger schaut und aufs Grün und ich mag allein mir vorzustellen, dass ich all diese Worte verstehe, so Driveway, Putt, Pa, Bogey, Bingy, Bilby, Eagle, dann auf Grün, Chip, Bunker, Sand, Baum, Schläger, Teich, Holz, sowas, ja, Caddy, Goldfisch, oh ich hoffe die Autos heißen Caddy, ne. Oh, da gibt es aber einen ganz fantastischen, ich glaube, Doku-Film über Kinder, die anfangen Golf zu spielen. Den Namen muss ich nachreichen.
Mini-Golf heißt der Film. Dieser Gag wurde Ihnen präsentiert. Von Kindern. Ich weiß nicht mehr, wie der Film heißt. Mega fantastisch, über Kinder, die anfangen Golf zu spielen und unglaublich gut schon sind und so Meisterschaften gegen sich selber gewinnen, so im U-12-mässig. Schläger sind grösser als sie und das ist ein ganz toller Film. Wie die aber von Eltern auch so gedrängt werden und das hat auch eine sehr emotionale Seite. Ganz toll, reiche ich nach. Das Einzige, was ich dazu beisteuern kann, und zwar, dass ich mal gehört habe, und zwar, ich habe gar keine Ahnung von Golf, aber ich ... Nee, nee, von gar nichts. Sagst du, Feuter. Ja, ist ja klar. Aber ich habe bei vielen Dingen so einen kleinen Tidbit.
So ein ...
Ein Conversation-Piece.
So eine Wissenspraline.
So, und die macht dich nicht satt, aber die gibt dir so einen Geschmack, wo du sagst,
ach, das ist ja ganz nett.
Und Florian ist ja gar nicht so bescheuert, denkt man dann.
Genau. Und bei Golf ist meine Wissenspraline die, dass ich mal gehört habe,
dass es bei Golfspielern durchaus relevant ist, wo die Sonne steht.
Diese Praline ist enttäuschender. Jetzt denken wir alle mal drüber nach, warum ist es für Golfspieler relevant, wo am Himmel die Sonne steht. Hat das was mit Anziehungskraft zu tun oder wo genau der Golfball fliegt oder so? Nein, Denn die Grashalme richten sich nach der Sonne aus. Und so kann der Golfspieler wissen, wie der Ball sich im Gras bewegt, oder? Diese Praline kam hinten raus. Die Praline war jetzt super boring und so und dachte erst auf Mokka, ach I don't know, das habe ich auch schon ein paar Mal gehört, so gesehen und geschmeckt. Und jetzt dann am Ende, hat die entfaltet, wurde noch ein bisschen scharf pikant hinten raus. Und jetzt muss ich irgendwie die Party verlassen, weil jetzt sind wir an dem Moment, wo alle feiern, wey, geil, und ich sage so, oh, da ist mein Uber, ich muss jetzt los, Leute, macht's gut, sorry, nein, geh nicht, geh nicht, du bist so cool, Leute, ich muss leider weg, ich muss leider raus, tschau. Aber genauso funktioniere ich auch, glaube ich, wie so ein Keyboard, was so auf dem ersten Eindruck jeden, jedes irgendwo was zu hat und so jedes Instrument spielen kann, nein, aber so man hat zu jedem Smalltalk-Thema oder sowas ein Titbit. Genau, so alles macht Spaß für zwei Sekunden, drei Sekunden und da habe ich so zu allem auch so ein bisschen und so, mein schlimmster Albtraum ist immer, dass wenn der Thema Jagd und dann weise ich ein paar Sachen, ein paar Pfandfälle. Jagd! Du bist auf Partys, wo das einfach nebenbei mal so, ich habe übrigens wieder wild gegessen letzten. Apropos, Apropos Wild, wusste der, dass bei der Jagd der Jäger ja wissen muss, wo die Sonne steht. Wo die Sonne steht, weil die sich nach der Sonne ausrichtet. Weil die Rehe ja dann in die Richtung gedrängt werden, wie das Gras steht. Ich dachte nur gerade so, Thema Beforstung, weiss man auch eh, was. Keine Ahnung. Und dann weise ich was darüber
und dann steht neben mir ein Förster.
Das ist das Grösste.
Aber auch in so einem Förster-Outfit.
Und nicht so, ja, ich hätte drauf kommen können.
Mit so fern Glas.
Lassen Sie mich mal Ihnen was zum Thema
Wild erklären.
Und zwar habe ich ihm Geolino gelesen
und der, aha.
Und dann sage ich so, ja und beim Golfen habe ich mal gehört die Grashalme und neben mir so, ja ich bin Professor Golfspieler und dann sage ich so, ciao, das war's, das war's, so, ciao, ich muss los, ihr seht mich nie wieder, ich wünsche euch allen ein schönes Leben, das war's, so wurde ich gerade entlarvt, ihr habt meinen Zaubertrick gesehen, neben mir ist ein Golfspieler, ich habe nichts mehr beizutragen, ciao, schönes Leben, und dann hört man draußen den Motor starten. Ja. Wenn du auf einer Party bist mit Peter Wohlleben, dem Waldexperten, und dann anfängst du erzählen. Peter Wohlleben? Peter Wohlleben, ja, der Guru, der, aber es ist ganz geil, weil ich bin, ich hatte meine Waldphase und hab mich versucht, für Räder zu interessieren. Diese Ironie, aber verstehst du schon, ne? Ja, klar. Peter Wohlleben. Ja. Und natürlich sorgt er dafür, dass es allen gut geht. Ja, klar. Und alle haben eine gute Zeit. Natürlich. Dass es den Wohlig geht, den weinen. Das ist so wie Herr Tierlieb. Der hat den perfekten Namen. Wo ich mir auch immer eine Blümchenfolge wünsche, wo der so ganz depressiv ist und so ich wollte nie Zoodirektor werden. Ich hasse Tiere. Aber war immer schon klar, Herr Tierlieb, ne, Walter Tierlieb? Es war immer schon klar, es war nie meine eigene Entscheidung. Es war dann so, ja klar, natürlich gehst du zum Zoo und ich habe dann als Schüler, als es hieß Praktikum und es dann in der Klasse umringen, so, wo kann man Praktika machen und so, war es bei mir immer so, ja Tierlieb, du gehst ja in den Zoo. So, das war gar keine Diskussion. Wurde nie gefragt. Also das war immer direkt, ah, nee, lass uns mal lieber nochmal bei Laura überlegen. Aber bei mir war immer klar, da müssen wir nicht eine Sekunde nachdenken. Ja, und dann habe ich irgendwann die Ausbildung angefangen und dann geht das ja fast von alleine. Ja, Sie hören NDR 2 heute mit unserem Talkgast Peter Thierlieb aus dem Neustädter Zoo. Es geht weiter nach einem kurzen Wort unseres Sponsors. Hey, habt ihr auch VHS-Kassetten zu Hause liegen? Kein Problem, bringt sie einfach rum, in Kisten, bringt riesige Kisten mit VHS-Kassetten rum, wir digitalisieren die, wir machen die schön, wir machen die, hör zu, wir machen die so schön, dass sie die zuhause gucken können, neunze Jahre Partys machen können.
Alte Erinnerungen, und es ist auch nicht zu teuer, ausser sie lang. Ausser sie haben viel zu lange, überlängend, ein bisschen rechtliches Verwirklichen zu sagen. Wir digitalisieren eure VAL. Naja, und irgendwann bist du dann Zoodirektor, ne? Was wollten sie eigentlich werden, Peter. Lieb? Naja, ich habe ja früher tatsächlich auch immer gerne gejagt. Sie haben Tiere gejagt? Also nicht selber, also ich war immer gerne im Wald und habe da den Jägerstand gesehen. Und dann bin ich da mal hochgeklettert auf den Jägerstand und dann lag da so ein Magazin noch drin, das war schon so ganz gewählt. Das stimmt, das da, das liegt, häufig liegen da noch Magazine rum. Ja, das war ganz interessant, weil das war so ganz gewählt, kennen Sie das, wenn Papier so nass wird und dann so wählt und man merkt, das lag da schon eine Weile im Regen und das war so richtig so ein Fund für mich als Kind, ich war da noch recht jung und das war für mich wirklich so ein Überbleibst, wie so eine römische Ruine oder so lag da dieses Magazin und Jägermagazin. Ja, beschreiben Sie das noch viel länger, beschreiben Sie das noch detaillierter, dieses Gefühl. Es war so ein, es gehörte nicht mir, es war sogar ein privates, da war ein privater Jäger, saß da oben und hat es gelesen und es war sogar noch aufgeschlagen, das Magazin. Ich konnte also wirklich genau da ansetzen, wo der Jäger aufgehört hat. Das war ein ganz
intimer Moment für mich.
Jetzt haben wir
einen Freund von Ihnen, einen
guten privaten Freund interviewt und gefragt,
was der von Ihnen hält, hier ist Benjamin Blümchen.
Ja, also ich habe
den Herrn Tierlieb kennengelernt,
da war ich noch ein
kleiner, ganz kleiner Fohlen. Genauso nennt er Baby-Elefant. Herr Benjamin, das ist ja nett. Herr Blümchen, nicht Herr Blümchen. Ach so, Entschuldigung, ja natürlich. Mit dem habe ich dann auch später viel zusammengearbeitet. Wie kam das zustande, die Zusammenarbeit mit Herrn Benjamin Blümchen? Er ist ja ein Weltphänomen, ein entsprechender Elefant gibt es sonst nicht. Korrekt, interessanterweise wussten wir das gar nicht, dass er sprechen konnte. Wir hatten damals das Angebot bekommen aus Namibia, vier Elefanten, drei Männchen, ein Weibchen. Da habe ich natürlich überlegt, ist das die richtige Entscheidung für so ein Zoo in Neustadt? Also Klima ist ja auch nicht unbedingt Namibia. Das war damals schon Thema. Ähnlich, das war Thema, ja sicher. Aber nicht, dass die Elefanten aus der freien Bildbahn. Nee, das ist natürlich klar. Sobald du den Fuss in den Zoo betrittst, gelten andere Regeln. Da sind Tiere natürlich auch keine Wesen mehr, sondern Ware. Das kann man jetzt aber als nicht besonders tierlieb bezeichnen. Ich glaube, du kannst innerhalb dieses Rahmens dann auch noch viel machen. Also die Existenz von Zoos ist ja, die wird es immer geben. Der Mensch wird immer gaffen. Warum bei der erste Assoziation eigentlich in den Zoo zu gehen? Ich meine, der Name Tierlieb, diese Dynastie Tierlieb könnte ja auch mal anfangen, weiß ich nicht, Tierschutzorganisation zu gründen. Schauen Sie mal, Tierlieb, das ist ja nicht irgendwie Rehlieb oder Schweinlieb oder sowas, sondern Tier, alle Tiere. Genau. Und für mich war immer klar, wo alle Tiere sind, das ist der Zoo, da findet man alle Tiere. Weil viele Leute, und wie Sie jetzt vielleicht auch, denken an Tier und haben im Kopf Katze, Hund, Bär. Aber das ist ja Unsinn. Tier ist ja auch Spinne. Ja, das können Sie ja auch Lager. Können an dem Punkt noch mal zu Ende bringen. Tier ist ja auch Mücke, Tier ist auch Schmetterling.
Das war für mich klar, dass ich da im Zoo an der richtigen Stelle bin.
Aber Sie haben recht, natürlich, es hätte anders.
Was war der Moment, und ich weiß, Sie haben in Ihrem Roman der Neustadler Zoo und ich die Memoiren von Herrn Thierlieb beschrieben, dass sie darunter leiden, dass sie immer auf Benjamin Blümchen angesprochen werden und nicht für sich stehen können.
Trotzdem möchte ich eine Frage noch mal zu Benjamin Blümchen stellen. Was war der Moment, an dem sie erkannt haben, dass er sprechen kann und wie ging das von sich? Naja, ich weiss noch, das war, da habe ich, ich habe ja immer Kaffee getrunken, weil der Stopp ist ja unglaublich stressig. Und du bist ja unfassbar im Stress die ganze Zeit. Diese ganzen Termine mit den Lieferungen von den Tieren, die können ja nicht eine Stunde zu lange im Lieferwagen sitzen. Ich meine, es kommt ja den Moment, wo sie gemerkt haben, dass der gesproken... Ich habe da so die Tasse Kaffee. Unabhängig von Kaffee-Diskussionen würde ich gerne wissen... Ich trinke, wissen Sie, ich trinke den Kaffee immer ganz gern mit zwei Stück Zucker. Ja. Und dann habe ich eben den Kaffee mir eingeschenkt und dann wollte ich so greifen in die Packung Zucker. Eine Minute, bis die nächste Werbung kommt. Bitte schaffen Sie es noch, die Geschichte zu erzählen. Und ich greife so und denke mir, wo ist denn der Zucker hin? Nee, Benjamin Blübchen. Ich frage nach Benjamin Blübchen konkret. Wo sind die Zuckerstückchen? Herr Th Tillib. Entschuldigung, aber bitte, Frau Heinrichsen, da müssen Sie jetzt auch mal zuhören.
Wo sind die Zuckerstückchen?
Und ich frage mich, ich kann doch jetzt meinen Kaffee nicht ohne Zucker genießen.
Auf jeden Fall schaue ich mich um und sehe, dass vorm Fenster steht ein Elefant.
Ich dachte mir, was ist denn da los? Ich habe das damals noch gar nicht zusammengefunden. Also der fehlende Zucker, die Zuckerstückchen und dieser riesige Elefant. Das war für mich was Unabhängiges zusammen. VHS-Kassetten! Ja, ähm. War ein Fehler. War ein großer Fehler. Für Herr Thierlieb. Für Herr Thierlieb hätte vielleicht was anderes machen sollen. Falls ihr einen Job anzubieten habt, falls ihr eine Bäckerei seid oder ein Schlachter. Oder, was ich viel spannender finde, habt ihr einen Namen, der zu eurem Beruf passt? Sehr gut. Wenn ja, da könnten wir mal nächste Woche so, weil Antenafrika oder sowas hat sich jetzt auch, sind wir ja durch mit allen Ländern in der Zwischenzeit, aber wir können ja mal bei, mal gucken, ob wir euch vorstellen, Menschen, die den gleichen Nachnamen haben wie den Beruf, den sie ausüben. Erzähl uns Hen oder Ei, was war zuerst da? Der Name, wobei es immer der Name zuerst, da fällt mir gerade auf, aber ähm, der ausser hier heiratet.
Naja, zum Thema Heirat, und da kann ich jetzt gleich mal ein bisschen Content klauen, und zwar von unserer, weil es gerade so gut passt und sehr lustig ist, von unserer fantastischen Kollegin Caroline Worps, die auch ihren eigenen Podcast Too Many Tabs mit unserem ehemaligen Kollegen Miguel Robitsky hat. Und die hat einen sehr, sehr lustigen Clip gepostet, den wir jetzt einfach klauen. Wir schauen uns das einfach mal gemeinsam einen Clip an. Aber im Internet gehört allen alles. Internet gehört allen und da geht es nämlich auch genau um das Thema, wie hängt die Berufswahl mit dem Nachnamen zusammen. Und zwar hören wir gleich Frau Hitler. Das ist eine Frau, die heiratet bald und die heißt Frau Hitler. Und die Frage ergibt sich natürlich in gewisser Weise, warum haben meine Eltern nicht schon das gemacht, was ich vielleicht gleich tun werde, nämlich den Namen meines Mannes annehmen.
Frau Hitler möchte aber weiterhin Frau Hitler geändert. Sie möchte weiterhin so heißen, allerdings ihr im Weg steht, dass ihr Gatte auch einen sehr attraktiven Namen hat.
Da hören wir mal kurz rein.
Sie heißen ja Frau Hitler, ne? Wollen Sie den Namen behalten? auch einen sehr attraktiven Namen hat. Da hören wir mal kurz rein. annehmen okay weil sie eine kleine also was heißt gleich weil sie eine firma haben
wurstwaren vertreiben okay und da passt der nachname natürlich irgendwie zu der heisst Ist das für Fleischer?
Nee.
Was?
Ähnlich.
Ist die schöner?
Fettköter. Echt.
Wow.
Mein erster Gedanke war, der heisst Mussolini und mir findet sie ähnlich gut.
Der hat Wurstware.
Stalin.
Der hat einen Vertrieb für Wurstwaren und da ist natürlich der Name ideal.
Und da denkt man schon, Senior Salami.
Schlachter, Fleischhauer. Nee, Fettköter. Ja gut, also da gibt es ja gar nichts dran zu rücken. Das ist ja perfekt. Das ist ja absolut perfekt. Das ist ja unfassbar. Aber mir gefällt alles in diesem Clip, wie sehr der um die Ecke geht und noch mal um die Ecke geht. Sie will den Namen Hitler aber sehr gern behalten. Oh Gott, aber das ist... Großartig, aber stell dir mal die Hochzeit vor, Hitler-Fettköter, fantastisch. Doppelname, bietet sich ja auch an. Fettköter-Hitler, finde ich eigentlich. Also vielen Dank an unsere Online-Archivarin, Caroline Worps, hört mal rein, in Too Many Tabs, ihrem fantastischen Podcast, dafür klauen wir weiterhin ihren. Connet aber ganz toll, aber klar, wer Fettköter heißt und in einem Wurstvertrieb arbeitet. Das passt ja wie Arsch auf einmal. Das passt ja fantastisch. Unfassbar. Ja, toller Clip, aber sagt mal Bescheid, wenn ihr einen Job habt und heisst auch so, heisst ihr Schlachter. Oder wenn ihr heisst die Nazi, heisst ihr Himmler, heisst ihr Göring, was hat das schon für witzige Situationen?
Die Einsendung ist wieder ein bisschen breiter.
Heisst ihr wie euer Beruf, im weitesten Sinne Schlachter, seid ihr Schlachter, Fleischer, seid ihr Fleischer.
Oder habt ihr einen Nazinamen, der auch zu eurem Beruf passt, seid ihr Waffenschmied und heisst Speer, sowas in der Ecke. Sowas suchen wir. Heisst ihr Göring und seid eine Göre. Ja. Oder seid ihr Pilot und ihr heisst Himmler. Ja, sowas in der Ecke. Also, falls ihr darf, also das wäre natürlich absoluter Bonuspunkt. Dann kriegt ihr einen doppelten Smiley ins Heft. Passt euer Name im weitesten Sinne zu eurem Beruf und oder habt ihr einen Nazinamen, der in Klammern auch vielleicht zu dem Beruf passt, den ihr habt. Dann habt ihr gewonnen. Ja, da habt ihr gewonnen, da habt ihr das Jahr gewonnen, dann sind wir schon durch. Und erst wenn wir denjenigen und diejenigen finden, hören wir damit auf. Ansonsten stellen wir jetzt jede Woche jemanden vor, schickt uns einen kleinen Audiobeitrag, schickt uns doch eine kleine Audionachricht. Ja, oder habt ihr vielleicht auch einen Namen, der gerade überhaupt gar nicht zu eurem Beruf passt, das kann ja auch witzig sein. Genau, versuch's mal bei Instagram, da könnt ihr uns Audionachrichten schreiben. Ja, und was Stefan meint, wenn er sagt, schickt uns Nachrichten, meint er schickt mir und ich kümmere mich drum und ich mache das alles. Nein, nein, nein, schickt ein. Ja, ich mache es ja am Ende dann doch. Ja, aber muss ja nicht, ich kann ja auch machen. Ja, gut, dann mach's doch du. Okay, dann haben wir das jetzt geklärt. Wow, weil das Giftfestival kommt alleine geschmissen. Das kommt ja nicht jedes Mal mit einem fucking Giftfestival. Ja. Könnt ihr immer noch auf unserem Instagram-Account nachverfolgen. Oh, das wurde übrigens veranstaltet. Wie? Vom Filmfestival Cologne wurde dieses letztes Jahr das Gif Festival ... Die haben unsere Idee geklaut? Moment mal! Ich war da. Können wir da nicht so ein Gif schicken, wo wir so mit der Faust ... Man konnte dann hier in Köln am Brüsseler Platz entlanglaufen. Alle Läden haben da mitgemacht und in jedem Schaufenster war ein Gif zu sehen. Ich bin ausser mir. Mit einem kleinen QR-Code, wo man ein paar Informationen bekommen konnte. Ja, es war genau so, wie man es vorstellt. Arschlangweilig. Aber cool. Das hätten wir denen aber auch sagen können. Also da hätten wir auch eingreifen können, als sie gesagt haben, schickt uns eure GIFs, hätten wir sagen können, Vorsicht. Nein, wenn wir sehr, sehr gute GIFs bekommen Falls ihr jetzt sagt, was, Giftfestival? Das ist ja völlig an mir vorbeigegangen. Keine Sorge, we got you. We got you covered. Wir haben auf Instagram das alles hochgestellt, das haben wir technisch hinbekommen, nachdem der Stefan sich ein kleines Booklet gekauft hat, Instagram für Anfänger, hat er das immer durchgeblättert und ist jetzt bereit. Jetzt haben wir heute gar nicht unsere tolle Detektivgeschichte weitererzählt, seid dafür gespannt auf nächste Woche. Ja, es wird weitergehen, falls ihr euch fragt, wer hat im Jahre 1666 London angezündet. Wir wissen nicht, wer es war. Aber es ist ein Mysterium, das ist all over the place jetzt. Weil wir haben gesagt, dass die Geschichte 1867 jetzt spielt. Wieso das denn? Haben wir gesagt wohl. Ein Hörer hat darauf reagiert. Es ist messy, wir müssen das sortieren. Wir müssen das nächste Woche aufräumen, ein bisschen Bergerungsarbeiten machen. Aber ich finde es gut, Bartholomew J. Barth wird weiterhin Lady Farnroy suchen. Ja, stellt euch auf weitere Abenteuer von Bartholomew J. Barth ein. Das wird so schnell nicht enden. Nein, das wird so schnell nicht enden. Da haben wir genug
Material. We got you covered. Listen.
Da haben wir genug Material.
Da hat ein Hörer fantastische Arbeit gemacht.
Und zwar bei Reddit, wo ihr auch mal
reinschauen könntet. Das Podcast-Ufo.
Das Podcast-Ufo hat er, ChatGPT,
GPT,
hat Bartholomew J. Barth in ChatGPT
eingegeben. Und wir haben tolle Prompts bekommen für weitere Folgen. Da habe ich richtig viel Spaß dran. Das machen wir auf jeden Fall. Ihr seid da nicht nervös und überschwemmt uns nicht mit Nachrichten. Kommt runter, kommt runter. Entspannt euch da mal, ihr kriegt weitere Bartholomew J. Barth Storys garantiert. Ruhig. Vielleicht nicht heute, vielleicht nicht morgen, aber sie werden kommen. Entspannt euch, entspannt euch, kommt runter, kommt runter, kommt runter. Das machen wir weiter, Bartholomew-J-Barth wird ermitteln. Bis dahin wünschen wir euch eine fantastische Woche, viel Spaß, viel Erfolg bei euren eigenen Aktivitäten. Und wenn sie nicht fantastisch wird die Woche, ist das nicht schlimm. Es ist immer noch Januar. Absolut.
Das ist der geborene Monat für Kackwochen.
Und seien wir ehrlich, es ist Samstag, die Woche ist mehr oder weniger vorbei.
Also jetzt könnt ihr auch nicht mehr viel falsch machen. Wieso, ich dachte, wünschst du für die nächste Woche.
Ciao, macht's gut, wir heben ab und wünschen euch eine schöne Woche.
Bis dahin, macht's gut, ciao!